he's been in here in person and i love
chatting with him and he does a great
job on uh
fox for both professional and collegiate
football
uh former head of nfl refs for the
national football league now along with
another former head of nfl refs and mike
pereira fox rules analyst dean blandino
here on the rich eisen show how are you
dean
i'm good i'm i'm just glad i'm no longer
the head of officiating today today's
not a good day that's what i'm saying
what what do you think is happening in
the league office today based on what we
saw at the end of monday night football
last night with tony corenti calling
cassius marsh for taunting by staring
down
the steelers bench
outside the night
they're reviewing i know if i were there
i would have had a conversation with
tony last night i wouldn't have waited
till today i would want to get his
perspective on what happened certainly
that call
on marsh you know what did you see why
did you call taunting and then and then
ask hey what happened there looked like
you bumped him did you lose your balance
it's
i mean it's hard for me to sit here and
say that i would imagine any world where
tony crenny would do that intentionally
but you watch the video and you go man
what the heck happened
so you know they're looking at all of it
they're reviewing the game like they
normally do and i would imagine they've
had conversations with tony and the rest
of the crew just to kind of figure out
what you know their perspective of it
well i mean
so
um
you knowing what this emphasis is this
year and your ear to the ground knowing
what's going on in the nfl
do you think the league wants that flag
in that instance against that
action by the player last night i i
don't i here's the thing there's there's
two ways to look at this there's
what the approach was and i think the
league the the competition committee the
coaches subcommittee which works with
the competition committee
they they saw a a decline in
sportsmanship they saw this in your face
stuff the the standing over the ball
carrier after the tackle getting in
somebody's face they saw that not being
called so they wanted to clean that up
and that's good and we've seen that
before
but it feels like we've gone another
step to where even listening to tony in
the pool report he said he was posturing
well you know if he didn't say anything
and he's just kind of staring at the
bench
i mean that's a that's a pandora's box
now i can i can i get the in your face
stuff i get the standing over look at me
we're gonna you know we're gonna that's
gonna lead to other things um
altercations later in the game you want
to nip that in the bud but this
again i wasn't there i don't know what
was said or what tony was seeing from
his perspective it just feels like a
another level and i'm not sure that is
what the committee intended no i mean we
i guess we could all assume what he saw
which is what the rest of us saw which
is we saw a player
you know start walking towards a bench
not his own
um strutting
and he maybe did not see the fact that
marsh said nothing he might have assumed
marsh was saying something and barking
he had no idea it was just a stare
because he's only seeing marsha's back
as he's walking even inching closer to a
bench
that he used to belong to by the way i
don't know if officials know history of
every single player out on the field but
he had no idea if he was barking at him
but isn't there any sense of
moment and contextualizing that needs to
happen here dean 3 30 to go in a game
whole country watching that's now a
three-point game you you you know what
the score is and what time it is why
throw the flag on that man why yeah and
and and look tony's a veteran referee
he's been around a long time and and he
has good judgment he's been a good
referee for a long time and you do hope
that in that moment look a foul's a foul
and if it's there you gotta call it
regardless of two minutes to go in the
fourth quarter or the opening kickoff
but
that moment it felt like i would have
wanted to see more look if marsh gets up
and he's in the steelers bench area and
he's john and he's up in somebody's face
that's a foul you can't do that but to
be kind of near midfield and just
staring it just felt like you could have
given him a little bit more of a benefit
of the doubt
and and then you get on top of that then
you get the flag and the bump and it's
just all
it's just tough to kind of
explain the whole deal it's it's it's a
tough one dean blandon dean blandino
here on the rich eisen show the thing
that i think that outrages fans the most
is not just because there's no context
in the call right there there is
you know a player that's performing this
um stare and strut but there's also no
context as i just said about 3 30 to go
force is a punt i'm gonna call this
penalty i know it's a fresh set of downs
i could essentially end this game right
now by doing this but i'm going to do it
anyway
that's one thing that outrages fans but
the thing that's the most outrageous is
the concept of lack of accountability
that that that you hurt you hear coaches
basically say and matt nagy said last
night guys have to know there's an
emphasis guys have to know that they
shouldn't even give
uh an official uh a thought in their
head to twitch towards their flag how
about the official not twitching towards
their flag how about something in their
head
to say i'm not gonna do it because it's
not worthy
of the foul at the moment how about that
dean yeah there's no question and and
officials are held accountable i think
it happens more behind the scenes it's
not out in the open it's not public so i
think that
explain
explain it folks there's an evaluation
system that game any game you're going
to get graded on every call you make
you're going to get graded on calls you
should have made you're going to get
graded on your mechanics your
positioning so there's former officials
that go through each game and they
evaluate the performance on a lot of
different levels
and then you get so for me if i'm
looking at that play i think it's what
does the league do with this going
forward do they say
good call tony that's correct we're
going to put that on a training tape for
every official to see that that's
taunting and we're going to we're going
to reinforce that that call and you're
going to see more of that or are you
going to take the approach look that's
not you made the call it's not a good
call we're going to give you a downgrade
we're going to put it out to the
officials to say we do not want this
call we want to see more here's some
examples of what we feel are taunting i
mean that would be the approach that i
would hope happens um but they are held
accountable and if you don't grade out
well you don't get a postseason
assignment and if you don't grade out
well um you are at risk of of losing
your employment with the nfl and
officials get let go every every off
season so there is a
an accountability it's a profession that
is under intense scrutiny you know i
can't think of other professions where
we're talking about it right you know
you we make decisions you're an account
you make a decision you might have made
a mistake you go home we're not talking
about it on the rich eisen show but it
is something that fans want they want to
know that they're held accountable i
guarantee you they are but again what is
the league going to do with this are
they going to say that's a good call and
we want to see that going forward or are
we going to say hey wait a minute that's
not what we intended and uh and we don't
want to see calls like that going
forward well dean uh you didn't hear
arrow one we called out a cpa and rancho
uh mirage uh earlier to say that they
screwed up somebody's taxes it was an
awesome guy yeah
fans are still calling in but in all
seriousness though you're i totally
understand the scrutiny but there is
an issue with the fans right now
certainly on this subject alone when it
comes to officiating is a credibility
issue this is definitely a pr
scenario what about doing what the nba
does put out a last five minute report
based on what we saw last night so
everybody knows was
tony corenti downgraded for calling this
taunting penalty on cassius marsh or
does the league say yes we want that
called i think it's important that fans
know that the league does or does not
want that
called we sat there we saw it it's a big
game it's week nine it's the difference
between potentially a team being four
and five and three and six and five and
three or five hundred it's really that
big
why not let it be known yeah i mean the
nba i think there's pros and cons i
think some of that it comes from a good
place i don't know if that's worked out
you know you've heard like lebron james
and others kind of be critical of the
two-minute report
i get it i think there would be some
value i don't know if i worry you know
because if you get all these reports and
you're seeing hey those officials made
eight mistakes in the last two minutes
that undermines their credibility as
well i think there's ways to do it
there's ways to communicate with the
fans whether it's social media
or having somebody from officiating come
out and say hey
let's look at the play here's what
happened here's what the officials saw
we don't think this is a foul we don't
want this going forward i think we there
needs to be more of that they didn't
have that early in the season you didn't
hear anything from officiating i think
they've started to head down that path a
little bit whether it's their their
twitter account or other things that
they're doing but i think that is
important because fans they they need to
know that i don't think you give them
everything because you just but you give
them something right to say yes we're
looking at this we understand there's an
issue and here's what we're doing to
address it so last one for you on this
uh if you were still the head of
officiating i'm making you just for the
split moment the head of nfl officiating
once again even though you started this
interview saying you're glad you're not
would you have downgraded tony corenti
for this or said good call what would
you say no i i don't think it's a good
call i don't you know i'd want to hear
from his perspective like we always did
but i would i would want to put that out
to our to our crews
that look guys this is not we want to
see more in the bench area we want to
see him in somebody's face um to call
this and and that that would be my
approach
um you know and whether there would be
something beyond that in terms of
communicating that to the public
certainly to the clubs you know to
chicago and pittsburgh you would you
would do that that's normal protocol but
i i just don't think there's enough
there to call taunting i don't care i
don't care if it's the first quarter you
know with 13 minutes to go i don't think
that is what the committee intended with
this point of emphasis yes do you think
that is happening today
um
to be honest your best guess i don't
know what's your best guess
my best guess
is they are going to
bend over backward to try to support
that call and i think you do that in
some instances because you want to
support your officials but there are
times where you just can't
um and my gut would tell me that i don't
know if there's going to be some public
proclamation that this was a good call
but my gut would tell me that they would
support that
that's unfortunate i'll be very honest
with you dean blandino right here on the
rich eisen show
let's talk about the concept of new york
that's what we're we're hearing all the
time that new york is charming and it's
new york it's new york uh i i do love
the fact that we're seeing flags picked
up we're seeing calls like uh that's not
a catch because the tow was out and
that's the ruling on the field and then
there's a huddle up and now up the
ruling on the field is it's a catch
because new york saw it's a catch it
saves the
coach from challenging it keeps the game
moving along and i love it i'm enjoying
this immensely why couldn't new york
have been chimed into basically getting
corinthie's ears saying hey tony before
you announce it hang on a second he
should huddle up with his officials just
give me a couple seconds and then you
know
even after he's thrown the flag give us
20 seconds because i know that it's a
head official that's throwing the flag
usually he'll just pop it on and just
say that's the penalty why couldn't new
york chime in and say he didn't say
anything tony i know his back was to you
pick it up why can't new york do that
stuff on 15-yard penalties all the time
about whether it was roughing the pass
we're seeing awful roughing the passer
calls we saw last night uh a penalty
call that took a bear's touchdown away
because t.j watt was apparently blocked
below the waist it was a whiff he didn't
get him like
why can't new york be chiming in more
often yeah i think i right now under the
current rules they're not allowed to and
a lot of that comes from the replay
official as well that video assist
i think that's going to be the
conversation going forward you know when
it is obvious that there is a foul that
is not there
um can they chime in and i think that's
that eventually i think we're going to
see some of that i think you're going to
see the you know the face mask call and
that he actually grabbed the jersey not
the face mask right and they pick it up
so i think that's coming i think we got
to be careful and mindful of you can't
you can't re-officiate the game from
from the replay booth that's just not
you know you're gonna you're gonna
destroy the flow of the game you can't
have officials being indecisive because
they know that they're that they're
gonna immediately be looked at but i
think in in game changing situations
i think that is possible where you could
have someone whether it's the replay
official or the people in new york that
can come in and say hey let's pick up
the flag that's not a foul look if we
had done that in the nfc championship in
2018 and and got a flag down for that
past interference we probably don't go
through 2019 with the replay review and
all of that nonsense you know yeah
exactly i mean there's so much that can
be corrected
certainly in everybody's watching
nationally televised games dean because
as you know from fox with the the buck
and aikman crew and last night for the
worldwide leader and sunday night
football etc there's all these 4k
cameras i mean you're seeing stuff it
looks like portrait mode sometimes on
your phone you're seeing it and and so
i'd love to see these things
get picked up more often it's a better
game for it and it moves faster
it really does but i'd love to see it
slow down a little bit before a 15
yarder is called huddle up because again
that makes it look like at least it's
coming from the field and we know it's
getting in their ear pieces
let's just do it let's do it
so yeah that's that and the technology
is pushing it the technology keeps
pushing it forward it's going to get to
the point where it where you can do it
seamlessly and like you said the the
video quality is so good and the angles
are so good right you're going to see
more information than the officials can
ever sit i got one last for you if you
have time dean one last one
did
pereira came on recently and i think he
said this so i'll repeat it he might
have already been uh uh a bit into the
tito's it was only 10 in the morning so
yeah um so uh did he say that you're
involved with maybe working on a
national
um sort of officiating crew like to try
to nationalize officiating in college
football did i hear that correctly yeah
so one of the things yeah one of the
things we're working on because i do
work with the ncaa on the replay side
we're looking at maybe doing some things
more regionalized like right now you
have right the big ten officials work
the big ten
don't get me started on that dean i know
believe me i know and then you have
these non-conference games when alabama
plays ohio state and then you've got big
12 officials it all right the perception
is well they're big 12 officials they're
gonna they're gonna lean toward oklahoma
not that that's the case but it is a
perception and so one of the things
we're looking at on the replay side is
can we do more of national replay
centers where whether it's targeting um
or or the the cfp games the neutral site
games where instead of them being big 12
replay officials or big ten replay
officials they're nca replay officials
they have no affiliation
and it it just gives you more of an
appearance of of you know an unbiased
look and that's something that we're
working on you know maybe testing with
the cfp some of these neutral site games
and we'll see how it goes okay um so who
was in the there's this big ten uh uh
replay bring up a source subject about
the you know the michigan state law you
were
were you in were you in the studio for
that one because i was too busy throwing
stuff at my television i could imagine i
know there was a couple of controversial
calls and and jim you know jim mentioned
a couple of things there was a you know
controversial replay review
um
controversial are you saying terribly uh
inappropriate and wrong is that what you
mean by controversial i mean that might
be the that might be the the michigan
perspective on that which i know you're
coming from
um but you know you're you're the
spartans maybe that's karma you know
they go and they lose to the giant
killer purdue boilermakers so it's it's
karma right okay no by the way when you
when you said michigan point of view
it's actually the 2020 vision perfect
eyesight point of view that's what that
was there was there's no reason for that
thing to be overturned
okay all right well you're doing the
lord's work improving uh officiating at
the collegiate level i'll tell you that
dean for sure so good luck with that
thanks for the call dean really
appreciate it today you got it dean
blandino everybody right here hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here